pas de tapis rouge au festival les clés
du cinéma samedi mais un parrain
d'exception mabrook elmcher MABR eler
c'est un réalisateur qui a qui est né à
Versailles et qui a vécu pendant 15 ans
il me semble dans cette
ville et donc naturellement on app à Mar
quelqu'un qui connaît bien la ville qui
connaît les jeunes c'est quelqu'un qui
qui est reconnu et renommé dans la
région et c'est d'ailleurs au clés
sousbis que maéerie a tourné ses
premiers courtmétrage à la fin des
années
90 le court-métrage est est un
laboratoire c'est souvent considéré
comme l'antichandre du long-métrage mais
je pense que ça sa spécificité c'est un
sprint alors que un long-métrage est une
est un marathon donc c'est pas la même
préparation c'est on tourne généralement
très très vite avec peu de moyens et et
avec beaucoup d'énergie le cléien est
aujourd'hui mondialement réputé pour
avoir dirigé dans ses films Jean-Claude
Van Dam ou encore Bruce Willis et aussi
pour la réalisation de la série Maison
Close diffusée sur Canal plus fort de
son expérience il était président du
jury lors de cet après-midi de
projection avec une vingtaine de films
en
compétition d'avoir un retour sur sur
notre travail c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
fait les les festivals qu'on qu'on va
dans les festivals et donc voilà ça sera
un plaisir de d'avoir son son avis pour
cette Dee édition le Prix du meilleur
court-métrage a été attribué à Bad Boys
une poursuite ça fait
longtemps l'événement gratuit pctué de
rencontr entre le grand public et les
réalisateurs a attiré près de 150
amateurs